[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to once
again this is the fourth time i'm saying
that now be discussing the events that
transpired in the harry potter universe
after the books and films ended
i've made three separate videos on this
topic to date parts one two and three
which each cover ten separate characters
and what they got up to post-deathly
hallows between those three videos i've
managed to cover
voldemort neville hermione ron harry
george luna hagrid draco the dursleys
umbridge fudge lockhart flitwick filch
ollivander kingsley shacklebolt pomona
sprout arthur molly weasley percy
weasley aberforth dumbledore fleur
seamus finnegan mcgonagall narcissa
lucius cormac mclagan grope rita skeeter
slughorn and dean thomas
today i'm going to be continuing that
trend and giving you part 4 of what
happened to these 10 characters after
the war i'll link parts 1 2 and 3 in the
pinned comment the new fantastic beast
films like the secrets of dumbledore
dropping this month are giving us new
insights into the beloved characters of
our childhoods releasing never before
seen information about their backstories
that got me thinking what happened to
these characters after the story had
ended today we're going to be taking a
closer look
number one charlie weasley though
charlie didn't make an appearance in the
films he was certainly present for the
battle of hogwarts and survived the
battle
charlie never married nor had children
but got to spend his time with his
copious siblings nieces and nephews
being an outdoorsy type with an affinity
for dragons charlie was more preoccupied
with his craft rather than pursuing
ladies apparently in the summer of 2014
nosy journalist rita skeeter began to
question his prolonged celibacy
something that was obviously none of her
business
2. civil tralani zebul trelawny hogwarts
divination professor fought valiantly in
the battle of hogwarts bravely
protecting her friends home and
livelihood and with a move like a tennis
serve she heaved another enormous
crystal sphere from her bag
waved her wand through the air and
caused the ball to speed across the hall
and smash through a window fortunately
truly survived the battle and afterwards
continued to teach well into the 2010s
continuing her tradition of predicting
the deaths of her students in the year
2020 trelawny published a book entitled
my eyes and how to see past them a book
that hermione granger kept on her
shelves in our office at the ministry of
magic
3. forensic forensic was a centaur and
part of the centaur colony located in
the forbidden forest forensic was also
the same centaur that saved harry in the
philosopher's stone
forensic notably replaced trelawney as
divination professor after she was
sacked by umbridge
though trelawny was eventually given her
position back at the school varense
stayed on and the pair co-taught the
subject
forensic was active in fighting back
against the death eaters during the
second wizarding war and eventually
sustained serious injuries shaking and
unable to stand by himself forensic was
laid on a raised platform in the great
hall during the second half of the
battle
fortunately forensic was able to survive
his injuries a special thanks to madame
pomfrey for that after the battle had
ended forensic was welcomed back into
his centaur colony where they were
finally forced to acknowledge that
ferenza's pro-human leanings were not
shameful but honorable forensic
continued to live out his days teaching
divination alongside trelawney
number four oliver wood oliver wood
attended hogwarts from 1987 to 1994 and
he is most well known for his passion
surrounding the game of quidditch
during his time at the school wood was
both keeper and captain of the
gryffindor quidditch team and was known
for his determination and skill on the
field wood graduated from hogwarts
before harry and many of the other main
characters in the story and went on to
join a professional quidditch team
puddlemere united where he began as a
reserve keeper however wood did
eventually return to hogwarts in 1998 in
order to offer his support in the fight
against voldemort and the death eaters
wood fought valiantly and also helped to
drag the bodies of the deceased into the
great hall
fortunately wood did survive the battle
and spent the rest of his days playing
professional quidditch his true calling
number five madame maxime madame olimp
maxime was a french witch and
headmistress of bobatore academy of
magic she was 11 feet 6 inches tall and
a half giant just like handgrid apart
from being enormous and the headmistress
of bobatore she is perhaps best well
known for her relationship with hagrid
apart from the book's initial signifiers
that the pair were possibly romantically
linked the relationship isn't touched on
much and eventually the goblet of fire
simply ends with maxime departing and
heading back to beaubaton alone this
left fans with one big question what
happened with hagrid and maxime
rolling once addressed hagrid's love
life in an interview did hagrid ever get
married and have children
oh did hagrid ever get married and have
children no
realistically hagrid's pool of potential
girlfriends is extremely limited because
with the giants killing each other off
the number of giant tessas around is
infinitesimal and he met one of the only
ones and i'm afraid she thought he was
kind of cute but she was a little more
how should i put it sophisticated than
hagrid so no bless him it turned out
that maxime simply thought she was too
good for handgrid it's certainly a shame
that maxime was the one that got away
but on the other hand i think that he
was probably the one that was too good
for her we don't know much else about
maxim's later life but we do know that
she continued on as headmistress of
bobatore 6. bill weasley bill weasley
was the first and eldest weasley child
though bill survived the war in the
copious battles that transpired he was
at one point severely injured by the
notorious werewolf fenrir greyback
fortunately he avoided turning into a
werewolf but it has been expressed that
he did develop the tendency to enjoy
very rare stakes following the war bill
and his wife fleur who he married in
1997 had three children victoire
dominique and louis weasley 7. pansy
parkinson pansy parkinson was a
slytherin witch in harry potter's year
at hogwarts the parkinson family were
purebloods and members of the sacred 28
a list of 28 pureblood wizarding
families during her time at the school
pansy was both a prefect and a member of
the inquisitorial squad
during the final battle of the second
wizarding war pansy infamously spoke up
in favour of turning harry potter over
to lord voldemort her words however were
not well received by most of her
classmates who drew their ones upon her
in harry's defense little is known of
what happened to pansy after the second
wizarding war or later life but we do
know that she fell out of touch with
draco
jk rowling said in an interview that
pansy didn't end up marrying draco
because she always hated her
i loathed pantsy parkinson i don't love
draco but i really dislike her she's
every girl who ever teased me at school
she's the anti-hermione i loathe her
8. aunt marge marge dursley was an
english mughal and vernon dursley's
oldest sister
marge was an extremely unpleasant woman
and you may remember one particular
visit to the jersey residence in which
harry could tolerate no more
after speaking ill of harry's parents
harry's magical abilities
unintentionally erupted in the form of a
non-verbal inflating charm which
resulted in marge's body inflating this
caused her to float upwards towards the
ceiling
marge was later punctured and had her
memory modified by the accidental magic
reversal squad from the ministry of
magic
after this incident the dursleys never
invited marge to stay again
and harry never saw her again number
nine patel twins padma parvati both
padma and parvati were active in the
battle of hogwarts and neither of them
have been listed among the fallen fifty
fifty unknown casualties in the fight
against lord voldemort and his death
eaters because of this we know for
certain that they survived the battle
there's very little information
available about their later lives but we
do know that both kept their
dumbledore's army coins and likely
attended the 2014 reunion of
dumbledore's army
10. ginny weasley it probably shouldn't
come as a surprise to anyone that ginny
ended up marrying the one and only harry
potter she was in love with him for
years and though the films didn't do a
very good job of portraying this
relationship they were meant to be
the epilogue of the film gives us just a
glimpse of the lady that ginny would
become where she is seen sending off her
children to hogwarts a platform nine and
three quarters harry and ginny had three
children james albus and lily
immediately after graduating from
hogwarts however it has been reported
that ginny actually became a
professional quidditch player going on
to play for the holy head harpies
in the years that followed the harry
potter series rowling provided other
clues about ginny's later life after
retiring to become a mother ginny joined
on with the daily prophet and became
their official quidditch correspondent
this position eventually matured and she
became the sports editor for the paper
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel who have i
missed who next leave a comment down
below until next time remember
words are in my not so humble opinion
our most inexhaustible source of magic
[Music]
you